what do you think was the wildest thing
that the cast got up to after filming
and what was it that made Jessie May Lee
realize that she had to stand up for
herself on set the filming of Shadow and
Bone season 2 certainly was wild so
let's get into it how do you put
together a world as magical as the
Grisha verse with the use of plenty of
green screens that's how the sea whip
was created by having the head stuntman
perform on set while wearing a green
morph suit and providing all of the
monsters noises Jessie May Lee remembers
filming that day as everyone's screaming
and shouting while splashing around in
this tank and says it was one of those
moments when I looked around and I
thought oh my God what are we doing
Jesse feels that moments like these are
what she loves about acting because
you've got to lose yourself in all of
this silly nonsense it would seem that
the time spent onset was almost as much
of a party as the cast's time off
so like the cast of Shadow and Bone got
along famously even if they struggled a
bit emotionally to get through filming
this season cast parties had become a
regular thing to get them through it
what happens in Budapest stays in
Budapest Jessie May Lee and KET young
were among the biggest Partiers while
Ben Barnes was the first to end the day
what happens after midnight Ben doesn't
know because gotten home to sleep there
was this one party where Danielle
Galligan told kalyn's gogman that he had
to show up dressed as Amita Suman
Callahan pulls up dressed as
to a party where we've all dressed as
kalaha and speaking of parties you can
join Ours by clicking our subscribe
button it's pretty much always a good
time here too bad that wasn't true for
our cast of Shadow and Bone maybe the
reason Jessie spent so much time
partying this season was because she
literally could not sleep she'd already
dealt with some pretty debilitating ADHD
but this season she also had to struggle
with chronic insomnia throughout the
shoot she tried not to let it get in the
way but she can still see just how
exhausted and stressed she was when she
watches everything back and like Jesse
was able to find a lot of support from
her co-stars but she still found that
she really needed to stand up for
herself during this time like filming
for season 2 really did become a period
of growth for Jesse where she really
learned how to set her own boundaries
and to be a bit kinder to herself but
Jesse wasn't the only one struggling
this season like how hard was it to see
Nina and Matthias separated this season
oh sure they had a brief reunion in
Hellgate but they shared very little
dialogue in that moment and had to
convey a ton of emotion using only a
single glance Danielle Galligan felt a
lot of pressure to get that moment
between them right thinking to herself
we have this one beat and like it was
hard for her to make a few lines heard
considering the amount of noise going on
in the scene already
but Danielle felt it was all worth it
for the scene that they got it in the
end in the book Nina doesn't even reach
Hellgate until it's time for her to
rescue Matthias but Danielle thought it
was just so much more heartbreaking to
have Nina see him before then being
imprisoned in Hellgate wasn't easy for
Callahan either he referred to season
two as the season of solitude for him
and he means that in both the show and
in my own life he spent the whole season
really longing to be with the rest of
the cast because he felt they were all
so close off screen even so he felt that
season 2 was maybe the most profound
season in my life of figuring out who I
am and like he found these moments to be
a blessing but he's still looking
forward to being able to work with the
rest of the cast because I think we can
make something very special we're sure
he was pretty disappointed to miss out
on some of the great sets they used for
this season too like have you noticed
the amount of detail they brought to
every set just look at moroseva's
Workshop which appears in season 2
episode code 6 the entire set was
designed to look as though the walls
were made out of rock and plenty of
details were taken straight from the
pages of the book specific designs
relating to the book were hand drawn
even the Scrolls that covered morozova's
tables were designed by hand it really
just keeps going our cast also spent a
lot of time aboard a ship it's like a
loft apartment really the ship was
actually just a set built in studio it's
an authentic ship definitely on water
and with that much control over the
design they were able to sneak in a
little secret think you know what it is
let us know down in the comment section
while we move on to the Easter eggs
hidden in the costumes did you notice
that Alina's clothes were a little
boring this season that was on purpose
costume designer wenny Partridge wanted
to make sure Alina's clothes reflected
the fact that she didn't want to draw
attention to herself that being said pay
close attention to the way that she and
Mal are dressed throughout this season
too because their clothes say a lot
about the state of their relationship
the costume designers claimed to have
taken influence from as many as 20
different countries for the Wardrobe
this season and they were able to
include references to the book
throughout so if you look closely at the
cruise codes you may even see the
grishaverse map hidden in the patchwork
the costumes really helped to set the
tone this season almost as well as the
music wylan may be a skilled floatist
and pianist but did you know that Jack
Wolf is a musician as well I played the
piano for a really long time Jack was
even allowed to compose the small piano
number that wylan plays for Jasper in
season 2 episode 3. I had the best
weekend like coming up with this little
sort of 30 second bit composer Joseph
trapanese helped him prepare by sending
him the kind of music that wylin would
be hearing in the clubs around ketterdam
it was important to Jack that the song
feels super personal considering how
proud he is of the relationship between
wylan and Jesper in season two Jack
feels their Romance is something I never
see very often because it's super
playful and really safe and they weren't
the only things heating up the set in
season two Jessie Mae Lee had a hard
time filming in Hungary although they
visited like a number of gorgeous
locations like this stunning library and
this awesome Palace for season two Jesse
found that hungry gets very very cold in
Winter and very very hot in summer and
said we were lucky to experience both
ends of the spectrum they spent some
time filming out of the same sand pit
where they shot Dune and Jesse
complained that the weather was so hot
that she could only dangle from her
harness exhausted even joking it was
very much time for me to have a good
sleep none of this helped her deal with
her insomnia but at least Jack Wolf was
having fun on set can you guess what
Jack Wolf's favorite day on set was
while filming in shuhan they brought in
a bunch of live alpacas and Jack was so
excited to to see them there was just
one problem all the other actors were so
tall that they were sort of blocking
Poor Jack's view I'm the only one to
shoot and so kit young and Freddie
Carter came up with a way for Jack to
see the alpacas both of them grabbed the
leg and lifted me up so I could see the
alpaca so Jack may not have been
expecting to be lifted over his
co-star's heads but the alpacas left him
with a perfect memory of shuhan Shadow
and Bone season 2 takes us to shuhan for
the first time a nation inspired by East
Asia in the 19th century a historian was
brought in to help production get
certain details right and this helps the
writers to sneak in a number of things
from the real world that Festival that's
actually a nod to the Hungry Ghost
Festival a real-life Taoist and Buddhist
celebration that pays respect to the
deceased this sits well seeing as the
episodes spent in chuhan are about
facing your past but then again time is
a trick Concept in Shadow and Bone you
can't trust what you think you see in
the finale one thing plays out on screen
while Kaz Brecker delivers a speech in
voiceover but these two things may not
be happening at the same time the
showrunner teased that the voiceover of
kaz's could actually be several weeks or
even a few months after the events we
see on screen season 2 may not have
followed the events of the book exactly
but it sure did keep things as
interesting behind the scenes as they
were on screen like how successful do
you think they were in telling the Crow
story this time around make sure to let
us know down in the comment section
[Music]